jimmy carter le coeur à nu les
américains touchés pour combien de temps
impasse au proche-orient anouar el
sadate se tourner vers l'europe
l'hépatite b vaincu par un vaccin
disponible en 81
non monsieur bonsoir on dit que
l'histoire ne se répète jamais bien ce
n'est pas toujours vrai la preuve la
marine à voile reprend du service et
vous allez voir le premier pétrolier à
voile et ce n'est pas une blague d'une
plaisante il s'agit d'un navire japonais
de 700 tonnes
ces voiles et les machines spéciales
sont prévues pour utiliser moitié moins
de carburant que des cargos de même
tonnage pleuvant au secours du pétrole
un paradoxe qui si l'on y réfléchit d'un
peu trop près frise l'absurde
cette petite ampoule contient le nouveau
vaccin contre l'hépatite b
mise au point par un professeur français
monsieur pierre maupas ce vaccin va
permettre de soigner et de sauver 200
millions d'êtres humains qui chaque
année dans le monde sont atteints de
cette maladie
une maladie qui en france touche vingt
mille personnes par an et provoque la
mort de 200 personnes en moyenne
car l'hépatite b la plus dangereuse elle
se communique principalement à
l'occasion de piqûres et d'injection en
général le vaccin existait depuis 1975
mais son existence néant du public
qu'aujourd'hui alors pourquoi c'est la
première question que fils du maire a
posé au docteur pierre gay fry directeur
médical raisons essentielles la première
c'est que les besoins sont importants de
ce vaccin il ya beaucoup de gens à
protéger et par conséquent il nous
fallait mettre au point une méthode de
fabrication industrielle de ce vaccin
la deuxième raison c'est que lorsque
l'on sort ce type de médicaments il faut
être absolument sûr que ce produit est
strictement anodin et d'autre part qu'il
est efficace
ceci nous a demandé de très nombreuses
années de travail car il a d'abord fallu
travailler sur le seul animal réceptifs
que l'on connaisse c'est le chimpanzé et
puis ensuite passer à des essais
cliniques à grande échelle sur l'homme
quand trouverons-nous ce vaccin en
pharmacie
et bien ce vaccin ne sera pas mis en
pharmacie immédiatement pour la raison
suivante les quantités produites seront
de l'ordre de 100 mille doses à peu près
soit la quantité nécessaire pour
vacciner environ trente mille personnes
auraient besoin
si on mettait
le produit en pharmacie seraient très
largement supérieurs à ceux ci donc nous
préférons dans un premier temps réservé
le vaccin aux sujets qu'ils ont soumis
au risque le plus élevé c'est-à-dire les
personnels des centres d'hémodialyse
d'ailleurs artificiel les gens qui
travaillent dans des centres de
transfusion dans des laboratoires
hospitaliers ou non et puis aussi ce qui
est intéressant peut-être pour vous les
sujets qui partent en voyage ou pour
séjourner dans des zones d'endémie élevé
c'est-à-dire les zones intertropicales
par exemple des jeunes gens qui partent
à la coopération pour travailler deux
ans en afrique de l'ouest au sénégal
sont soumis à un risque très élevé et il
est bien entendu évident que nous devons
protéger ces gens là de même des
vacanciers qui même pour une durée de 1
mois parts dans une région tropicale
sont soumis à un risque élevé et par
conséquent pourront se faire vacciner en
se rendant dans un centre de vaccination
spéciale à gré c'est une victoire
importante
c'est une victoire importante car on
estime actuellement qu'il y a environ
200 millions de personnes dans le monde
entier qui souffrent de cette maladie
d'une part et que d'autre part dans la
vie on connaît pas d'autres
intermédiaires de ce virus à l'exception
du chimpanzé on peut espérer lorsque le
vaccin sera largement diffusé arrivé à
interrompre le cycle d'infection d'un
malade à un autre d'un malade à sujets
sains qui deviendra malades par
conséquent de voir disparaître la
maladie progressivement billy carter
regarde son frère le président le
défendre et se défendre lui-même à la
télévision la nuit dernière au cours
d'une conférence de presse à la maison
blanche
commentaire de billy jimmy a été très
bon en tout cas ce qu'on peut dire c'est
que le président américain a fait le
maximum pour se dégager de cette affaire
de relations douteuses qu'entretenait
son frère avec la ligne il a vraiment il
n'ya pas d'autre expression tout déballé
y compris des notes personnelles qui
figure dans son journal intime qui tient
depuis qu'il est à la tête des états
unis affirmant en conclusion que les
relations son frère avec la libye n'ont
aucune influence sur la politique
américaine et que par ailleurs billy
carter n'avait jamais non plus cherché à
l' influence
afp acx
trinidad dont elle est membre est née
lors aucun mérite ni impôts ni fraîcheur
pour les meilleurs
in fine nous accrocher à la normale à
quelques carottes nq inc fraude au fait
qu'on m'a dit on n'y a que le bio
minister d'afrique
cette r8 et nibali administration au
fond le président américain hier soir a
fait un aveu mon administration at il
dit n'a rien de comparable avec celle
qui a provoqué le scandale du watergate
mon administration est intègre et une
faute a été commise avec mon frère billy
j'en suis le seul responsable
or on est maladroit incompétent dit
certains c'est bien l'image que se font
les américains de leur président
toutefois ce matin les réactions sont
plutôt favorables
les américains et les amis politiques
monsieur carter pense que ce dernier a
bien contourner l'obstacle billy et
qu'il n'ya plus d'affaires billy carter
c'est aller vite en besogne répondent de
leur côté les républicains qui pensent
au contraire que tout n'a pas été dit
sur la sphère billy carter si bien qu'à
moins d'une semaine de l'ouverture de la
convention démocrate à new york
les ennuis ne sont pas apaisées pour
monsieur carter ses amis démocrates qui
veulent battre les républicains monsieur
reagan par tous les moyens sont prêts à
le sacrifier pour parvenir à la victoire
il respecte l'honnêteté de leur chef de
file mais s'ils veulent plus un chef de
file par exemple il serait fort capable
de refaire l'unité du parti démocrate
divisés notamment par la rivalité carter
kennedy est capable de dominer monsieur
reagan qui caracole en ce moment
nettement en tête dans les sondages
et c'est bien pourquoi la sphère billy
carter a fait autant de bruit car dans
moins d'une semaine
jimmy carter sera si c'est son propre
frère qui a ruiné sa carrière politique
en effet si donc d'après les premiers
sondages l'intervention du président
américain comme le disait jacques séguy
a été reçue favorablement par l'opinion
publique et les milieux politiques mais
pour l'instant sa cote reste au plus bas
elle est l'aboutissement d'une série
d'erreurs et de malheurs qui se sont
abattus sur jimmy carter depuis son
accession à la présidence une accession
qui était basé sur sa probité
après le scandale du watergate ya bien
un sourire éclatant jimmy carter en
novembre 76 il vient d'être élu à la
tête des états unis il est au fait de la
popularité
pourtant lui qui déclare 'mettre la
morale à l'origine de toute politique ne
va pas tarder à connaître ses premiers
déboires en 77 d'abord son ami burke
lines secrétaire d'état au budget et
conduit à quitter le gouvernement
on reproche à la banque de georgie qu'il
dirige d'avoir accordé des prêts trop
généreux à la sphère d'arachide des
carters ap lines au moment où jimmy doit
affronter une campagne électorale
coûteuse jimmy carter et finalement
innocentés
n'empêche les faits et fâcheuses autre
source d'ennui les multiples incartade
du frère billy que l'amérique appel
billy la bière billy par le trop et
accumule les dettes et les gaffes en 79
il soulève un tollé en injuriant les
juifs américains et contraint jimmy
carter a affirmé que son cadet n'est pas
antisémite
toutefois billy ou sa soeur gloria
continue de défrayer la chronique par
les écarts de leur vie privée
enfin en avril dernier ce produit
l'échec du raid sur l'iran critiqué pour
son comportement dans la sphère des
otages de téhéran jimmy carter joue et
perd un nouveau coup dont le titulaire
de la maison blanche a bien du mal à se
remettre
aujourd'hui la côte de jimmy carter est
au plus bas les événements que nous
venons d'évoquer ne peuvent tout
expliquer il faut y ajouter les
problèmes économiques et en particulier
l'inflation mais il contribue réellement
au déclin de la crédibilité d'un homme
qui dirige le plus fort pays du monde
demain auront lieu les funérailles des
victimes de l'attentât de la gare de
bologne aujourd'hui le président du
conseil italien monsieur cossiga a lancé
un appel à la solidarité de toutes les
forces politiques du pays avec nous en
direct en compagnie de notre
correspondant victor vraiment monsieur
payette à l'un des principaux
responsables du parti communiste italien
alors monsieur payet a d'abord cet
attentat provoque un sentiment d'horreur
générale en italie
oui tellement ça c'est la tante à la
catastrophe la plus grave depuis la
guerre et et nombre de victimes qui n'a
pas de précédent genk et d'autres
attentats avaient le même but mais c'est
là c'est vraiment quelque chose
d'effrayant parce que et ne visait
personne qui pouvait très considéré par
personne l'ennemi s'avisait des enfants
de chantier ou les deux premiers jours
de vacances
et si c'était bombes ont explosé une
heure avant ou une heure après c'était
la même chose
vous êtes vous-même à bologne les
spaghettis et après nous avons mis cette
nouvelle
on était moi j'étais avec nos camarades
quand vous avez pologne maire communiste
un président de région communiste et je
vends une deuxième injection ne plus
forte et où j'ai été mobilisés avec les
autres partis avec les autres forces
avec la police les sapeurs pompiers
l'armée et jeudi et naturellement on
devait se souiller les larmes par les
régler par un mais la chose qui m'a
frappé le plus si vous voulez même
commencé mais résiste 1 c'est la preuve
de force de fermeté démocratique du thé
national
non cela ne rôde pas le courage ni et
l'engagement dans la lutte vient alors
justement aujourd'hui monsieur cossiga
le président du conseil a demandé la
solidarité de toutes les forces
politiques du pays mais un article de
monsieur berling werle secrétaire
général du parti communiste italien dit
qu' il y à vacances du pouvoir et qu'on
l'interprète comme un refus de cette
solidarité mais non mais là elle est
plutôt insolite et nous sommes là bas
nous avons des piles et dans toutes les
rues les places d'italie drapeaux
communistes socialistes démocrates
chrétiennes ensemble
on pourrait s'interroger si la voir
monsieur kossi a cédé force et
d'autorité pour appeler les insurgés
berry et nationales qui c'est nécessaire
pensez vous qu'il ya vacance du pouvoir
comme le dit monsieur berling wayne
allez vous voit pas profiter de cette
situation pour demander finalement
définitivement entrer dans le
gouvernement je vous prie il corriger un
des mots que vous avez employé
nous n'allons pas profiter certainement
pas de 85 ans est morte pour poser un
question d'un trait au moins au
gouvernement
nous sommes engagés dans ce moment de
voir qu'est ce que la démocratie était
liens dans son ensemble qu'est ce que
peuvent faire les partis politiques et
les organisations
vous vouliez les institutions pour
défendre la république et qui est menacé
et pour faire notre de waele vers les
victimes de la barbarie terroriste
merci monsieur est à plus de trois cent
mille personnes ont manifesté la nuit
dernière à téhéran en faveur des
étudiants iraniens actuellement détenu
aux états unis entendaient ainsi
protester contre les sévices qui
auraient été infligés aux 171 iranien
qui font la grève de la faim en prison
aux états unis et qui désormais vont
être de nourri de force par leur gardien
l'amérique n'a pas été la seule à
attaquer au cours de cette manifestation
des slogans invitaient la population
musulmane durée cesse à se révolter
demandant également qu'une marche soit
organisé sur jérusalem pour la libérer
dans cette atmosphère passionnel
l'amiral madani qui avaient pourtant
accueilli près de deux millions de
suffrages lors de la dernière élection
présidentielle a été déchu de son mandat
parlementaire accusé d'être un agent des
états unis l'intolérance semble être la
nouvelle maxime à la mode dans le monde
on vient de le voir et elle se traduit
parfois de bien curieuse façon trois
hebdomadaires arabe de paris un câble de
reproches la vedette libanaise de
variétés sabah qui récemment au cours
d'un grand échiquier de jacques chancel
sur antenne 2 à chanter en compagnie d
une rico macias chanteur juif c'est la
seule chose que lui reprochent ses
journalistes
vous propose de revoir un extrait de
cette émission l'objet du délit comme
dirait
comparé aux autres
l'espagnol
là
oumma
y est elle est là
ban est là à lille
les pays arabes réclament l'aide de
l'europe pour aider à régler le problème
du proche orient
à preuve l'entretien entre messieurs
jusqu'à téléphonique entre monsieur
giscard d'estaing et sa date
à preuve encore les déclarations du roi
hussein de jordanie qui insiste sur la
nécessité pour l'europe de combler le
vide politique précédant les élections
américaines ou encore une preuve la
visite de monsieur gaston thorn à
beyrouth où il a rencontré monsieur
yasser arafat de leader palestinien ce
président du conseil des ministres de la
communauté européenne en exercice il
s'est déclaré convaincu qu aucun
règlement ne pourrait se faire sans la
participation de tout le monde
les supports vraiment indiqué désaccord
avec les rênes notamment la question de
jérusalem et celle de l'état palestinien
alors georges bartoli à quoi doit-on
attribué cette convergence de prises de
position vous et il ya deux genres de
fait oublier à ce que fait la france est
ce que fait l'europe mais vous allez
voir c'est convergent bon alors
l'initiative européenne le monde avoir
c'est celle de monsieur thorn qui
représente l'europe institutionnelle
l'europe des neuf au moyen-orient pour
essayer de résoudre le problème
palestinien
ce n'est pas lui qui l'a décidé bien sûr
ce s'est décidée au sommet européen de
venise en juin dernier et la france
avait fortement poussé à cette
initiative
bon pourquoi l'europe c'est bien simple
c'est parce que l'amérique est absente
direction faible prochaines élections
donc l'amérique ne peut rien
actuellement pour résoudre la question
palestinienne il ya un vide qui est
avide dangereux il faut le remplir donc
l'europe est là pour le remplir et
c'était évidemment l'idée qui sous
tendait le voyage de monsieur giscard
d'estaing dans le golfe
dernier de c'est pourquoi justement la
france a poussé à s'initient à cette
initiative
bon maintenant deuxième chose qui cette
initiative intérêts celle du côté arabe
bien entendu tous les pays arabes qui
ont refusé les accords de camp david qui
ont jugé qu'ils étaient insuffisants
trop partiel trop bloquant si je peux
dire
mais fait nouveau il ya quelqu'un
d'autre qui est intéressé par l'europe
c'est le président sadate
alors là c'est le deuxième ordre de fait
c'est cette conversation qu'on tue au
téléphone monsieur giscard d'estaing et
le président salade ça témoigne de deux
choses d'une part que les relations
franco égyptiennes n'étaient pas
mauvaises mais qui était disons un peu
détendus depuis que la france avait
manifesté de chez une réserve devant les
accords de camp david et le président
égyptien avait été un petit peu étonné
bon mais ces accords de camp david ne
donne rien rien parce que israël est
totalement intransigeant rien parce que
l'amérique ne peut plus rien faire
donc le président sadate à son tour et
c'est là que ce soir témoigne qu'il est
intéressé par ce que peuvent faire les
européens pour éteindre un incendie un
incendie qui peut mettre le feu au monde
entier si on n'y prend pas garde
merci change pas nouvelle vague de
violence en turquie 14 personnes ont été
tuées pendant les dernières 48 heures et
puis ce matin en france à lyon deux
hommes ont attaqué le considéra consulat
général de turquie blessant quatre
personnes à coups de pistolet le consul
qui était dans son bureau n'a pas été
touché au moment de l'attaqué
à paris quatre personnes armées de
pistolet de gros calibre se sont emparés
de plusieurs centaines de cartes
d'identité de passeports de cartes
grises cela s'est passé à l'antenne de
la préfecture de police de la mairie du
14e arrondissement
de nombreux barrages installés par les
policiers n'ont pas donné de résultat le
parlement belge a voté ce matin à une
écrasante majorité la loi sur la
régionalisation qui accorde des pouvoirs
d'autonomie pratiquement à la flandre et
la wallonie ce vote devrait permettre de
désamorcer en quelque sorte
l'éternelle querelle linguistique qui
paralyse la vie politique de ce pays
mais attention le cas de bruxelles ville
francophone en territoire flamand et qui
est le principal sujet de discorde n'a
pas tout d'un toujours pas été résolu
malaise entre les jésuites et jean paul
ii cet ordre religieux très indépendants
semblent avoir quelques problèmes avec
le vatican
puis la démission de son supérieur
général père a regroupé le processus de
succession étaient déjà engagés lorsque
jean paul ii a demandé que tout soit
arrêté une décision que la compagnie de
jésus n'a guère apprécié philippe
harrouard lorsqu en 1534 ignace de
loyola a fondé la compagnie de jésus des
contemplatifs dans l'action il ne se
doutait pas que les jésuites or émail à
partir bien souvent avec l'autorité
papale
certes ce bataillon de choc de
l'évangélisation
aujourd'hui 27 mille membres est lié par
un voeux de fidélité à la personne du
souverain pontife
mais les prises de position de ces
théologiens d'avant garde auront valu à
ceci des remontrances de la part du
vatican notamment après le concile le
fait que jean paul 2 et demandé au père
a rope et le général des jésuites de
surseoir à sa démission et d'arrêter le
processus visant à désigner son
successeur indique-t-il qu'il y à un
nouveau malaise c'est que les jésuites
représente un vrai pouvoir
comme le dit l'historien pierre miquel
qui vient de préparer une émission pour
antenne 2 sur ce sujet jésuites sont
tous company une compagnie c'est une
institution
et dans cette institution il ya un
certain nombre de procédés de discussion
avec le peuple quand on dit qu'ils
obéissent au pape paiera d akkad avait
comparé les allées fait rire
en réalité il ya toutes sortes de
processus de communication de bons ils
obéissent au pape c'est une chose
absolue ça c'est vrai ils sont là pour
obéir au pas mais ce n'est pas une
puissance aveu via en particulier
quelque chose qui s'appelle la
représentation et la présentation pour
un jésuite ça consiste à expliquer ou
pas les conséquences des choses qui veut
faire on lui dit écoutez voulais faire
ça c'est très bien
nous représentons que ça implique telles
et telles conséquences
et si le pape dit ça fait rien on le
fait à leur rôle fait on a quelquefois
appelé le supérieur des jésuites le pape
noir
une expression que n'apprécie sûrement
pas jean paul ii la cgt demande audience
à monsieur raymond barre pour discuter
du problème des allocations familiales
aux retraités et aux chômeurs privés de
ressources
monsieur michel d'ornano le ministre de
l'environnement et du cadre de vie qui
préside aujourd'hui une réunion du
conseil d'administration de la fondation
du parc naturel de la camargue a annoncé
la suspension du projet de stockage
souterrain de gaz sur le territoire de
lac
une de cayrade le ministre a d'autre
part également annoncé l'interdiction
prochaine de l'accès et de la
circulation des automobiles sur la plage
de camargue entre l'embouchure du rhône
et les saintes maries de la mer
michel d'ornano a aussi dit que l'état
apporterait son aide à l'aménagement de
nouveaux terrains de camping cela
pourrait limiter le camping sauvage en
ce qui concerne le languedoc enfin le
ministre de l'environnement a annoncé
une réduction de moitié de
l'urbanisation prévu à la grande motte
et le conservatoire du littoral qui
achètera à la grande motte des terrains
le long de la côte
plus de 400 personnes sans abri à la
martinique après le passage du cyclone
tropical allen pourtant le vent qui
souffle et des orientations dans
laquelle les habitations les habitations
pardon sont les mieux protégés martine
laroche-joubert la mise à arracher mer
démontée
l'oeil du cyclone allen n'est pas passé
très loin de la martinique
avec 240 kilomètres à l'heure sa
puissance égale qu'elle de david
ce cyclone qui l'année dernière avait
provoqué la mort de plusieurs centaines
de personnes dans les caraïbes
il n'y a eu aucune victime à la
martinique où la population a
strictement appliqué le plan orsec
mais de nombreuses bananeraies l'une des
ressources essentielles de ville
détruire la guadeloupe elle aussi a été
relativement épargnée seuls des récoltes
ont été endommagés par contre dans la
petite île de sainte-lucie l'ouragan
aurait fait sept victimes à la dominique
une haleine poursuite aujourd'hui sa
route vers haïti et la république
dominicaine
demain le conseil des ministres va
adopter de nouvelles mesures pour
favoriser l'enseignement de la musique
principalement la musique qui connaît
actuellement un renouveau les français
s'intéressent de plus en plus aux
classiques comme on dit et à l'opéra
alors comment expliquer cela jean
françois kahn tellement le phénomène il
est assez extraordinaire je vous donner
un exemple un seul parce qu'on pourra en
prendre plusieurs il ya trois semaines
au théâtre antique d'orange
il y avait un grand récital johnny
hallyday johnny hallyday plus sylvie
vartan les deux d'un seul coup et en
plus la publicité disait avant leur
rupture
c'était marqué dans le programme et où
vous remplir la salle il ya eu cinq
mille personnes c'est pas mal mais
quatre jours avant au même endroit pour
rigoletto de verdi
il y avait eu douze mille personnes sans
compter tous ceux qui n'avaient pas pu
rentrer mais pas avant la rupture de
rigoletto à la verve et voilà alors là
vraiment c'est un phénomène est assez
étonnant les français si vous voulez
redécouvre la musique classique en
général et particulièrement cet aspect
très sophistiqué pourtant la musique
classique qu'est le grand opéra alors
pourquoi on peut penser naturellement
les raisons le progrès culturel pour l
éducation le rôle de la télévision
incontestablement les choix qui a deux
autres raisons particulières
l'une d'ordre technique c'est que c'est
très à la mode aujourd'hui surtout quand
on arrive à un certain stade cadres
moyens tout ça d'acheter un appareil
haute fidélité avec des baffles avec
tout ce qu'il faut quoi s'occuper les
voisins sans s'occuper des voisins où
l'on met d un sonorisateur alors quand
on a ça et puis commence à écouter son
chanteur préféré ou même chopin au piano
dit à quoi ça sert d'avoir tout ça si
c'est pour écouter simplement et
chanteurs ou du chopin alors on se met à
acheter
ben de leurs quêtes et des choeurs et
puis de l'opéra
parce qu'on s'aperçoit que l'opéra ça
rend bien quitte à avoir ça autant voyez
avoir vraiment de la grande musique avec
coeur et c est finalement à force
d'écouter
on y prend goût et on veut en savoir
plus on achète on n'y va pas je crois
que c'est une des raisons
l'autre raison c'est que le théâtre de
plus en plus en france a évolué ces
derniers temps vers la simplicité à
outrance plus de décors plus de costumes
trois personnages etc
il n'y a plus de cirque eux non plus bon
les français sont sevrés de spectacle
qu'ils ont besoin de spectacle et alors
ils ont découvert qu'il ya un mois un
endroit où il ya encore des spectacles
des costumes de la couleur
des masques qui bouge sur la scène plus
de la musique c'est l'opéra et je crois
que c'est une autre raison qui explique
enfin quelles que soient les raisons
c'est un phénomène important il est bon
je crois que conseil des ministres ce
planches ce renouveau de la musique en
france qui ça ferait demain donc à
bonneval sur arc petit village de savoie
comme on dit sur les cartes postales
toute la population a mis la main à la
pâte plutôt ciment pour préserver
l'aspect rustique et montagnards de leur
commune
la montagne aux montagnards ça pourrait
être le titre du reportage de didier
regnier et michel adiko gilbert andré le
maire de bonneval a dit un jour nos
montagnes sont comme une toile de
bruegel ou comme un concerto de bach
cessons de les détruire aux montagnards
qui les habite d'envisager leur
aménagement 20 ans d'efforts ont ainsi
fait de bonneval-sur-arc un village
pilote ou la protection de
l'environnement est une réalité
quotidienne
c'est comme ça c'est à dire ceux ci
c'est un coffret électrique
l'électricité arrive dans ce coffret
repart vers la maison il ya absolument
aucun fils d'axel le souci de
l'esthétique a conduit les habitants de
bonneval à m sous terre tous les réseaux
électriques et téléphoniques soient plus
de 56 kilomètres de câbles la recherche
de l'harmonie guide de la même manière
ceux qui construisent les maisons nous
respectons les impératifs du site de
l'environnement notamment sur l'emploi
des matériaux tels que la pierre du pays
et sur l'emploi des bois les voitures
portent essentiellement le mélèze nous
tenons compte des conseils des habitants
notamment sur le choix des matériaux est
sûre
les conditions climatiques à 1850 mètres
d'altitude en ce qui concerne la
charpente on a déporté de lui mettre
l'emphase bien avec les avec les bois
que tu as trouvé probable qu'on va le
métro ne peut pas encore dire quoi duval
brut 1 tout ce qui ne furent pas pour
mettra du beurre en broche ici le
dialogue n'est pas un vain mot et c'est
à l'architecte de s'adapter aux
exigences des habitants en refusant la
démission du montagnard qui vante son
pays et se vend lui-même les bonnes
valeurs entendent rester maîtres chez
eux et décider seuls des aménagements à
réaliser pour accueillir le citadin
ainsi ont été construits 40 chalets en
pierre 130 box de garage sont enterrés
sous la montagne et 90 toit recouvert de
lauzes les villageois prennent des
initiatives décident ensemble et
contrôler ainsi totalement le succès de
leur entreprise
l'action des habitants ne s'arrête pas
là toutes les familles se sont endettés
pour construire des gîtes destiné à
accueillir les citadins bond à 8 bonnes
balles
allez allez mourir comme comme beaucoup
de villages mentale et les jeunes
risquait de partir alors j très
l'agriculture en arriver puis à vivre
donc il fallait faire quelque chose
et puis on s'est réuni avec le maire
toute la population les chefs de famille
et puis on a décidé de lui faire une
station mais une station où l'on voulait
pas de promoteur
donc on a pris le risque de re de faire
des gros emprunt et puis de faire nous
même l'air de travail dgt
aujourd'hui le bilan est largement
positif en 12 ans 15 e citadines ont
épousé des bonnes valin et la population
est passé de 130 à 172 habitants dont
65% aux moins de 25 ans
côté commerce le système fonctionne
simplement le fromager par exemple ne
perçoit aucun salaire mais un simple
pourcentage sur ses ventes tandis que la
vente sur place des produits locaux
économise les intermédiaires et le
transport ainsi bonneval sur arc est il
devenu une petite entreprise florissante
où chacun reste son propre patron
têtu un peu travailleurs beaucoup fier
certainement les bonnes valin ont réussi
leur village ici on parle peu mais on
agit avec le bon sens et après ce bol
d'air pur la météo pour demain après des
éclaircies matinales le ciel deviendra
très nuageux sur le nord ouest du pays
il bruine ra pas facile à dire pour des
côtes ailleurs le temps sera ensoleillé
avec cependant quelques nuages passagers
voilà ce journal se termine pas la main
vous présentera les dernières
informations aux environs de 23h30
demain pierre barret jean-noël gurgand
auteur d'un livre sur les compagnons du
tour de france seront les invités eux
d'antenne de midi bonsoir à tous je vous
retrouve donc comme un excellent de
soirée sur antenne 2 au revoir